hey guys it is the fifth of October my
name is Jess and you're watching games
but news the sub req lore is getting a
bit of a makeover and a free trial the
free trial lets you play the first 30
minutes of the game and if you decide to
buy the full game once your time is up
all progress and achievements are
carried forward Microsoft have also
detailed a new update for the game which
decreases loading times and adds new
audio and visual improvements the patch
is also making changes to the game's
waypoints collision locations
checkpoints and the respawn points you
can find the free trial on xbox one and
pc in other news the creator of dark
souls has said he feels unworthy of
comparisons between the dark souls
series and Nintendo's Legend of Zelda
header taka Miyazaki told LIXIL when I
was a student The Legend of Zelda was
truly monumental so to be perfectly
honest I feel deeply unworthy of the
comparison The Legend of Zelda and dark
souls are different games belonging to
different genres though and they guided
by different concepts of game design
they don't need to aspire to the same
ideals if there are similarities they
probably stem from the fact that the
legend of zelda became a sort of
textbook for 3d action games Miyazaki
went on to say that getting lost in the
world of dark souls was pivotal to the
experience and the kind of game they
wanted to deliver finally there's been a
bit of drama over on the no man's sky
subreddit which was temporarily closed
one moderator decided to close a
subreddit and purge all its content
deciding that the forum had become a
hate-filled waste whole of no actual
discussion he went on to say it's not
what we intended it to be and I don't
like providing a platform for hate the
subreddit has since been brought back
online with the new moderator claiming
they're hoping to get things going again
in a more positive way no man's sky has
been the source of a hell of a lot of
controversy the most recent of which is
an investigation by the UK's Advertising
Standards Authority into potentially
misleading advertising that is
everything I've got for you today do
head to games but for all the things you
need to know about playstation vr and
all our reviews and i will see you again
tomorrow